quelle drôle d'épisodes comme j'en
parlais avec heroes j'ai l'impression
que on est face à l'avant dernier
épisode de la série dark c'est le genre
d'épisode ou entra compte des éléments
manquants etc et qui symbolise vraiment
genre le calme juste avant la tempête du
grand final quoi oui c'est vrai que tu
m'as dit ça ah bah tiens il rotella
profite donc tu sois là pour avoir de
belles théories dans la vidéo ouais mais
j'ai ma vidéo sur l'épisode à faire moi
aussi inquiète les gens iront voir ta
vision des choses
juste après bon trêve de blague juste
avant de commencer sachez que vous êtes
très nombreux à regarder les vidéos sans
être abonné à la chaîne c'est le moment
de le faire pour ne louper aucune des
prochaines sorties et je vous avoue que
l'un en ce moment il ya du taf va y
avoir des théories bref comment sont
dans le hard et le vif du sujet nous
devons tout d'abord expliqué la magie du
chaos
ce genre de bail quoi dans les comics la
magie du chaos c'est ce que vous voyez
déjà à l'écran manipulation de réalité
des formations de l'existence création
de la vie etc
c'est ce que symbolise wendat sauf qu'à
l'origine ce pouvoir appartenait à une
sorte de dieu donc c'est pour vous dire
le caractère ultime de cette magie ce
dieu sera finalement scellé par d'autres
et à la naissance de wendat ce dieu se
manifestera à elle lui insufflant une
partie de ses pouvoirs
car elle est née un endroit précis quoi
ce qui a fait que wendat possède la
magie du chaos etc etc
évidemment ce sera différent dans le mc
eu mais c'est juste pour que vous
puissiez visualiser comprendre la chose
et justement cette magie du chaos est
symbolisée comme une sorte de magie
ultime quelque chose de très dangereux à
pouvoir qui dépasse totalement une
simple humaine par rapport au mc u et
dans mon idée
le dieu en question n'existe pas
spécialement mais est interprété par la
pierre de l'esprit la pierre qui
manipulés par idra est à l'origine des
pouvoirs de wendat et de son frère
pietro quand ils ont voulu s'engager
pour changer le monde
comme le dit agata harkness c'est la
pierre de l'esprit qui amplifiera les
pouvoirs de luanda au pouvoir qui aurait
dû s'essouffler s éteindre caruana
n'était qu'une humaine qui n'avait pas
conscience de tout ça et c'est ça le
truc il y a un côté élu chez rwanda
comme nous le montre la scène à idrac
personne n'a survécu à la pierre et
surtout ces dernières montrent une
vision du potentiel à venir de luanda
devenir la scarlet witch la sorcière
rouge
ce qui est intéressant également et
qu'agathe à souligner que wendat est
censé être une légende
elle l'est la sorcière rouge ce qui
voudrait dire que sorcière rouge est un
titre conférée par la pierre de l'esprit
à un élu qu'elle aurait potentiellement
choisi est ce que vous comprenez l'idée
et je suis obligé de vous parler de
doctor strange de oui encore une fois
tout simplement car la série est liée à
ce film est également spider man 3
doctor strange 2 est nommé comme
multivers of madness
voilà vous suivez et beaucoup
l'interprète comme la folie de ouandda
car c'est quelque chose qui est attendu
et encore plus du coup maintenant avec
la révélation de la magie du chaos un
pouvoir si grand qu'il peut conduire la
personne à la folie néanmoins pour moi
c'est trop tôt c'est trop prématuré que
wendat deviennent l'ennemi public numéro
1 donc et si la folie parlait justement
de la multitude de réalité existante en
quelque sorte le multivers est immense
les réalités sont très nombreuses bref
une sorte de folie des grandeurs vous le
savez tous l'arrivée du multivers est
imminente et sera le point central du
film de doctor strange de stephen
strange qui prend le rôle initial
d'agathe art en devenant très
certainement le futur mentor du rwanda
donc simple idée comme ça mais si le
film nous raconte est donc le voyage de
ces deux héros à travers les réalités
pour découvrir l'origine
du statut de scarlet witch comprendre ce
pouvoir sombre et anciens et
possiblement découvrir les autres élus
de la pierre à travers les réalités qui
étaient les possibles première scarlet
witch
bon j'avoue je commence à partir un
petit peu loin mais c'est un sujet qui
est vraiment fascinant pour revenir à la
série deux choses me bloque comme vous
savez au rwanda n'étaient pas seuls à
acquérir les pouvoirs de la pierre de
l'esprit pietro lui aussi en a eu
qu'est ce que cela signifie du coup
est-ce que pietro était une sorte d'élu
lui aussi de la pierre s'il était encore
vivant
aurait-il été un possesseur de la magie
du chaos et si c'était quelque chose de
familial j'ai souvenir que dans les
comics la véritable mère de rwanda et l
ancien scarlet witch avant l info à
revérifier mais l'épisode nous laisse
suspecter que wendat possédait déjà des
pouvoirs avant sa rencontre avec la
pierre donc est-ce que les véritables
origines de rwanda et pietro ne sont pas
celles que l'on croit
c'est trop difficile à définir pour le
moment et pour continuer quand est-il
d'agata son rôle devient de plus en plus
flou pour moi au fil des épisodes dans
les comics elle est là mentor de wendat
sauf que ce rôle sera normalement pris
par strange dans le mc eu
il semble que cette dernière ne soit pas
véritablement hostiles à luanda alors
quel est son but
il se peut qu'à gata soit une simple
antagonistes de série mais néanmoins ça
sonne un petit peu faux pour moi il
serait possible que cette dernière
devienne un personnage secondaire dans
le mc les sorcières sont peu nombreuses
et ont beaucoup de détracteurs comme
heures hayward
par exemple dans une future possible
alliance pour survivre il se pourrait qu
agatha aide rwanda avant de chez pas
genre allait faire sa vie de son côté et
tu sais quoi mais qu'est ce que je veux
dire par là exactement
tout d'abord un ennemi récurrent de
doctor strange très attendu pour son
deuxième opus et vous le connaissez tous
et oui c'est bordeaux le grand ennemi de
strange qui juge que le monde possède
trop de sorcier ce dernier est donc
l'ennemi d'akata aussi et la fameuse
règle de l'ennemi de mon nez
mhi est mon ami s'applique clairement et
ensuite on passe à hayward
hayward qui a menti purement et
simplement à tout le monde
affirmant que le corps de vision a été
dérobé par rwanda pour le faire renaître
et l'épisode nous révèle tout l' inverse
rwanda n'a jamais kidnappé le corps de
vision elle a voulu lui dire au revoir
et dans son chagrin à recréer un autre
vision grâce au pouvoir du chaos un
vision qui correspond parfaitement à
l'image qu'elle avait lui donc que cache
et ward exactement dans l'idée est mon
humble avis et ward est simplement un
businessman il est le mec qui a grimpé
les échelons pour arriver à la tête du
sword kit possiblement a tué maria rambo
pour pouvoir prendre sa place et non
être choisi un comme il l'a déclaré à
monica ce dernier a eu l'occasion de
mettre la main sur le court de vision
car déjà ces derniers faits de vibranium
en matériaux quand le trouve qu à candas
et qui est protégé par son peuple a la
base je préfère le rappelait wendat
ayant mis un sacré bordel à west view
étonnant en otage toute une ville
hayward a profité de la situation pour
faire d'elle l'antagoniste en manipulant
les images des caméras de surveillance
pour faire croire à sa folie comme ça
plus d'empathie pour les ex avengers
vision et wendat du coup il a carte
blanche pour faire de vision une arme et
attaquer rwanda avec est ce que vous
voyez l'idée la magie du chaos
permettant de créer la vie et ward a pu
se servir de l'énergie créée par wenta
pour faire revivre vision et le formater
à vaincre au rwanda et là je vous avoue
que ces méga intéressant quels objectifs
et quel avenir prévoit disney concernant
le personnage de vision la symbolique de
l'épisode autour du personnage et même
depuis le début de la série nous montre
que wendat n'arrive pas à passer à autre
chose mais
elle n'a pas le choix le deuil est même
expliqué depuis la bouche de vision
aujourd'hui ce personnage symbolise le
deuil que wendat doit faire par rapport
à son âme soeur mais c'est là le souci
comme tease et dans une finition noire
souris a le pouvoir de faire renaître et
reconstruire vision sans lapierre donc
vision peut revenir à alors pourquoi
cette thématique du deuil
que va-t-il advenir de vision au cours
du futur affrontement entre la sorcière
rouge et le synthé zoïde est ce que nous
finirons sur un adieu définitif du
couple ou est-ce que wendat
réussira-t-elle à faire revenir son bien
aimé cet épisode était vraiment
particulier et j'espère que ma vidéo
vous aura plu
la prochaine fois c'est le grand final
la fin de la série et accessoirement le
début d'une nouvelle ère le début de
l'arc du multivers à vous de dire vos
idées vos théories en commentaire je
prendrai un petit café et je lirai
évidemment tout ce que vous avez marqué
avec grand plaisir
évidemment je vous partage ma vision
voilà cette blague commence à être un
petit peu trop récurrentes
bref ma vision des choses propres à moi
et mes idées si ça vous intéresse
d'ailleurs la mire au cfa a évidemment
fait lui aussi une vidéo sur l'épisode
numéro 8 que je vous invite à aller voir
et qui est disponible dans la
description et j'apparais d'ailleurs
également dedans n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à laisser un petit pouce bleus
écoutez c'était argot rock et que le
'lion' hard soit avec vous allez ciao
tôt monde
[Musique]